position cuny all the things that struck
me when I meant what I think it's from
Romans injures are here not there being
any such thing as science without
science that has the baggage unexamined
so I twenty years in my career you know
more than hundred Asians and all that I
take the time to go back to graduate
school become a philosopher so surely
the scientists will take me seriously
because I'm one of them the philosophers
were taken seriously because actually
did em hard work of reading every one of
Plato's dialogues usually interesting
actually
beautiful questions and earlier that's
weird
interested in the China's economy lost
like talking about flaws of your mind
but it has been a great great right so
far and in my general approach to that
is that science and philosophy are
different what you're thinking in
different ways of doing things and in
part they do deal with
kinds of questions that they both belong
to what it used to be called Cynthia a
larger version of a larger concept of
knowledge the best thing we can do about
it it's just intellectual respect of
both enterprises despite the number of
scientists or philosophers who do spend
their time doing in terms of current
projects I have a new book at the comic
book coming out for the US Chicago Press
next year on the positive pseudoscience
or what's normally called the imitation
problem goes back to popper it was ad by
Larry Laden in the 80s and now I'm a few
other people got together thinking
actually probably something else that
can be said about ever to be said about
it yes sorry the difference between what
is the difference between science and
pseudoscience or science and non science
in general which goes to all sorts of
interesting issues can you actually come
up with reasonably sensible definitions
of concepts such as science and
pseudoscience what is the use or what
are you doing that
back up on an hour brought up the
question of question for pride in the
philosophy one of the things that I'm
doing right at the moment in fact is to
write a book about progress in
philosophy because I I find that
philosophers are very highly
self-flagellating
individuals they are hyper critical
about their own discipline and sometimes
for good reasons but that is not one of
them as you know I start from a box with
several of you I assure you it was
always in
you know positively constructive way to
restart with the intention why because I
believe people have mentioned if you use
several times I think I'm the only one
actually has a - well it's and the quote
is truth Springs from argument amongst
friends and he's going to be the general
idea of his work as well as far as
changing my mind
well I just did recently it's dance oh
that's all him James Lee Nieman wrote
this book that he mentioned earlier and
I happen to we did with a bloody
students this year and he really did
change my mind open the new vistas and
all sorts of things so I now find myself
changing my mind about certain aspects
of naturalism also fear mathematics
certain implications metaphysic
metaphysical implications I could change
my mind back frankly
you